good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here it's wonderful to see so many
students and faculty and staff and
members of the community gathered here
today to recognize Veterans Day to all
of our current and former servicemen and
servicewomen who are here today thank
you very much for your service you have
our deepest gratitude and respect Yale
students and graduates have served with
distinction in every major conflict
since the Revolutionary War that legacy
of service continues today we're proud
of the many students who currently serve
and the Reserve Officers Training Corps
on our campus and we are proud of our
faculty staff alumni who are veterans we
support our veterans through the Yale
veterans Network the campus group for
students faculty and staff and the Yale
Veterans Association an alumni
organization we want to support all of
our veterans and so I'm asking for your
help here's how you can help employees
can log in to workday and identify
themselves as veterans if you wish to
this is part of our veterans account at
Yale veterans count at Yale initiative
this is not a requirement but it helps
us give back to those who have given so
much to our country today we also mark
the hundredth anniversary of the
Armistice ending World War one which is
why when I was a child this was called
Armistice Day 9,500 Yale students and
alumni served in a civilian and military
capacity in the Great War
they included members of the first Yale
unit the nation's first naval air unit
Yale College
students actually organized this unit
even before the u.s. entered the war
others served in the Medical Corps the
Red Cross and allied armies 224 L
students and alumni were killed in World
War one the Cenotaph normally-on Hewitt
quadrangle honors them and their names
are called carved into the walls of
Memorial Hall just outside Woolsey Hall
the names of seven major battles
inscribed on the exterior of Commons
serve as a reminder of the war and its
impact on Yale and on the world these
memorials and ceremonies like ours today
are vitally important they ensure that
we never forget the human toll of war
men and women have made and continue to
make extraordinary sacrifices in service
to this country
we gather here today out of gratitude
and respect so thank you for joining us
to honor our veterans not only today but
every day of the year it's now my
pleasure to introduce Janet Linder yells
vice president for human resources and
administration who will say a few words
about today's program thank you all for
being here Jenna
Thank You president Sall of a good
afternoon I'm very privileged to be here
today as we honor our veterans
throughout its history Yale has been
home to women and men who have dedicated
their lives to the service of their
country we gather today to acknowledge
them and reflect on the freedoms and
privileges that their sacrifices have
made possible for each of us we are
honored to have among us today students
faculty staff and alumni who have served
or who are preparing to serve thank you
so much for coming today and being here
with us ceremony brings together the
best of Yale as you will hear from a
staff member a current student a
distinguished professor of history and a
Yale College graduate each has served or
contributed to the well-being of
veterans and each is a valued member
member of our Yale family they represent
commitment to honor and country across
multiple generations and conflicts they
represent all the veterans here with us
today and those who care for them our
music is provided today by students from
the Yale School of Music as we mark the
hundredth anniversary of the end of
World War one we're fortunate to have
our treasure veterans but also to firmly
re-establish within the fabric of our
university culture the 116 cadets and
Midshipmen of our Air Force and Navy
ROTC programs these young women and men
in uniform are a welcome sight on campus
as they fully engage in the Yale college
experience and meet their military
training commitments we offer special
thanks to their leaders especially our
commanding officers Air Force colonel
Tom McCarthy and Navy captain Wayne Graz
doc for the contributions that they are
making both of these young men and women
to our country and certainly to Yale in
the last four years
Yale students have increased their
activities around public awareness and
advocacy for veterans and we are
grateful for those students efforts Yale
students for veterans are again this
year creating a field of flags
on cross campus each flag placed in the
ground honors a veteran important to
someone at Yale I invite you if we
haven't yet and visit the installation
on cross campus it is stunning
during the next two years the Hewitt
quadrangle and Cenotaph will be restored
but Memorial Hall in Wolsey does remain
open as an inspirational reminder of the
names classes and records of service as
president salva said from the
Revolutionary War
onward please consider taking a moment
to reflect on those of Yale with
faithfully taken oath to protect and
serve it is my pleasure to now call upon
the officers of the OU University Police
Department who serve as our color guard
please stand as they offer the
presentation of the colors followed by
the playing of our National Anthem and
then please remain standing for the
invocation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon grand architect of the
universe called by many names in many
languages by many voices today we ask
that your guiding hands hold us and all
sisters and brothers in military service
near we are grateful for all who now
serve all who have served and for those
who in the words of President Abraham
Lincoln gave the last full measure of
devotion in service of their country we
are joined in humility gratitude and our
own measure of devotion knowing that as
we seek to understand an increasingly
complex world we are sheltered by the
vigilant service of citizens of our
Republic we ask special regard for those
who have served but who have not yet
been found and returned home and for
those who have returned but who have yet
to find themselves at home we honor our
military and ask that whoever is
whatever is required of them be informed
by your infinite wisdom as they
tolerably and loyally seek to create a
peaceful and secure future for us all
good afternoon everyone my name is
Hillary browning I'm an Eli Whitney's
student and Navy veteran I'd like to
begin by thanking president salva and
secretary golf crews and many others for
hosting this ceremony and thank you to
Dean Saudi and the rest of the
organising community for trusting me to
give these remarks and thank all of you
for joining us today typically when
people are chosen to speak at events
like this it's usually because they've
done something worth mentioning
for example I'm sure that at least a
very small part of the reason I stand
before you today is because I'm the
first female student veteran in the Eli
Whitney students program but today I'd
like to focus on some things about
myself that you wouldn't find in any bio
or on any resume my resume wouldn't tell
you that on the first day of boot camp
when a drill instructor yelled at me for
not writing in all capital letters I
burst into tears yeah it's okay to laugh
or that I failed my first physical
fitness test in boot camp because I
couldn't figure out how situps worked it
would never tell you that I got setback
two weeks in training in boot camp for a
disciplinary infraction it would never
tell you that during my six months of
journalism training following boot camp
I received about 20 counseling tips for
being late which as most of you know is
a big faux pas in the military it
wouldn't tell you that I continued to
receive counseling tips for being late
when I arrived in my first command in
Japan my resume would never admit to you
that I made a five-way before I was
ready for it and it would certainly
never tell you that the only reason I
was chosen to serve as an individual
augmentee no Afghanistan was because my
chief was sick and tired of dealing with
me and just wanted me out of the office
for a few months if the Navy could fire
people I would have been let go many
times over I'm grateful that resumes and
BIOS define us by our successes however
it's not typically success that shapes
your life its failure and
disappointments and sometimes even a
stack of counseling chips that help you
grow and mature if I hadn't been a
nightmare of a junior sailor I wouldn't
have been shipped off to my deployment
and I wouldn't have met Air Force Master
Sergeant Greg Bluth Minh Tech sergeant
john archiquette or Marine Sergeant Josh
wood - for
through their work and actions showed me
that I had a long way to go before I
would live up to my rank
they made me realize that my confidence
was wholly unearned and that I needed to
shut up listen and learn in the military
someone cares if you're not in the right
uniform if you don't show up for pt if
you're behind on qualifications and if
you're late especially if you're
supposed to relieve them from watch when
you're a junior enlisted member your
name is on someone's checklist and their
name is on some mean eins checklist this
means that your failures or mistakes
don't get to go unnoticed your NCO will
notice if you're late if you're out of
regs and if you're not pulling your
weight because being on a team means
everyone else is depending on your
success 20 civilians in the room these
efforts might seem excessive or a little
invasive but a beautiful thing about
this Big Brother esque tracking is that
you are forced to learn from your
mistakes and the military has all kinds
of creative punishments I mean
corrective measures for example if you
are late to work you may have to stay
late that day or come in painfully early
the next day or clean the most
disgusting part of the shop perhaps you
forget a piece of gear for a training
exercise congratulations you are now
wearing that piece of gear no matter the
size no matter what else we're doing for
the rest of the week now if you mess up
enough times or mess up big enough yes
you will receive some kind of formal on
paper in-person counseling with an e7 or
above in the room but most military
leaders know that that is not the best
way for you to learn the best ways are
when you get corrected on the spot in
front of everyone when you have to
witness the consequences of your mistake
or when the guys and engineering cut off
your hot water and weakened your water
pressure so you're forced to clean
yourself by shivering under a dribble of
ice water sorry I'm having carrier
flashbacks another benefit of the system
is that you are forced to live up to
your leadership expectations by never
being allowed to get away with the small
stuff and being forced to own up to your
missteps you learn to grow and mature
and become the kind of person who can
handle them
massive amounts of responsibility that
the military will demand of you I'm
grateful for all the annoying
infuriating and even embarrassing things
my leadership put me through in an
effort to help me grow and I'm grateful
that my chief punished me by sending me
on deployment because I was able to
correct my actions in my own time and
was given the space to fully appreciate
what it meant to have people rely on me
and what it meant to be worthy of my
rank I hope I became the kind of leader
they thought I could be I'd like to
thank those in this room who dedicated
themselves to military service each of
you have made many sacrifices in the
name of your service miss birthdays
missed holidays and quiet moments alone
with your families you've done this so
that others may live and sleep in peace
I commend you for staying true to your
oath to honor and serve our country
especially when it wasn't convenient or
easy for you when I look around this
room I see such a diverse spread of
servicemembers past present and future
each of you has answered the call and
each of you contribute to our history
heritage and traditions with your own
unique stories and special chapters of
service and our bond of camaraderie and
community is unparalleled which is why I
want to take a moment to close and leave
you with this thought last week I found
out that someone I was close to during
my time on the Eisenhower had committed
suicide he was known for always having a
smile on his face was always ready to
lend a hand and was admired and
respected by many on the ship he
organized an annual 5k to honor another
shipmate who had committed suicide he
made a seven in less than seven years
and was currently coaching a Special
Olympics baseball team to the outside
world he looked successful healthy and
happy with the rise of social media it
has become easier to stay in contact
with the friends that we make even when
they're stationed on the other side of
the world however it has also made our
friendships a bit more passive we could
all do more to maintain real connections
with those who matter to us kindness and
compassion have to go beyond clicking
the like button and people will never
forget the way that you make them feel
suicide is a heartbreaking reality in
the military community
and I'm sure it has touched many people
in this room so today on Veterans Day I
ask you to reach out to your fellow
veterans to your shipmates your devil
dogs your battle buddies and your
wingmen reach out not just to the ones
who look like they may be having a hard
time but to the ones who look as if
their lives couldn't be going better
someone may be fighting a personal
battle but no one has to fight it alone
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
president salary miss Linda Dean's
Veterans of America students of Yale
ladies and gentlemen had exactly 100
years ago yesterday on the 11th hour of
the 11th day of the 11th month of 1918
Yale soldiers and Connecticut soldiers
stopped firing
Yale Airmen based in Belgium and France
were ordered to cease firing the German
government had requested and been
granted an armistice in the fighting
that armistice lasted the two sides
victors and defeated then negotiated the
terms of surrender and the terms of a
peace that followed in June 1919 the
first world war the Great War was over
the end of the shooting the Armistice of
one hundred years ago has been marked
all over Europe this week in great
cities and in small villages in churches
and on town greens and no wonder direct
battlefield deaths in the First World
War
totaled over 8 million men indirect and
related deaths civilian deaths due to
war deaths by war diseases were well
over 10 million souls though many
earlier conflicts had also been long and
bloody they had been nothing like this
of that size I think I was first told of
those turtles ladies and gentlemen of 18
and 20 million deaths when I was
studying European history in high school
over 50 years ago
they seemed incomprehensible figures
then and it's just as hard to comprehend
them today although the United States
came late into that conflict the losses
suffered by its armed services were
still considerable about fifty nine
thousand in direct action about a
hundred and ten thousand when later
deaths disease casualties and other
causes are included had the fighting
gone on into 1919 it is clear that those
figures would have been far larger as
America share along the Western Front in
France was planned to surge as it was
two million American men and women these
nurses included had been sent overseas
by the war's end and another two million
were in training is it any wonder that
the newsreels and press photos of
November the 11th 1918 show the new
nation cheering and in relief at the
news that day that the fighting was over
but country then began to pay tributes
to the veterans who returned unto those
who were lost in the war we came to
memorialize them to put our public
monuments in their honor to list their
names just a month ago here in New Haven
on the city green there was a read
education ceremony of the War Memorial
built to recall this region's Amon
soldiers and sailors and those names on
the plinth for once again read out the
monument is over there just five hundred
yards away from the front of this chapel
and another five hundred yards away in
that complex of buildings wrapped around
Banneker Plaza is Yale's own War
Memorial when we walk through that
archway with Commons on one side and
Woolsey Hall on the other we stride past
those limestone walls itched with the
names of Yale's fallen in this First
World War and in many other wars only
eighteen months had transpired between
America's entry into the war in April
1917 and this armistice in those months
two places just outside here were a
whirlwind of activity the old campus and
the New Haven Green became the leading
training ground in the country for the
fast-growing US Artillery arm Yale
students 18-year olds were being
processed through the newly founded ROTC
science and engineering professors were
at work for all branches of the US
military so too were many members of the
Yale Medical School who pioneered
incidentally the country's first mobile
hospital unit in France by 1919 Yale was
a sort of giant gothic training camp
hardly a university at all in 1925 the
official Yale study a two-volume book
entitled
gaile in the world war provided all the
details a grand total president salary
just mentioned this a grand total of
roughly nine thousand five hundred year
man and graduates and students had
served in the war including in the Red
Cross YMCA over in France and other non
governmental bodies jelly's had served
in every conceivable military unit from
the air service and medical corps to the
Signal Corps the motor transport Corps
the engineers the field nurses in France
the chemical warfare service even the
coast artillery over 1,100 men were
officers in the US Navy
eighty-eight in the Marine Corps 1700 in
the field artillery 50 were chaplains
and 880 of them were in the various air
services it was such a huge rush to be a
pilot and this a mere 14 years after the
Wright brothers had taken to the air
quite a number of Yale EES also fought
in the Allied armies some also in their
Air Force's 50 fought in the Royal Tank
Corps 13 of them gained the British
military cross the highest award for
gallantry and 3 gained the Distinguished
Flying Cross a full a hundred and sixty
to Yale EES were awarded by the French
government of the day the quadriga for
valor which is a truly remarkable number
227 jelly's died in this conflict the
First World War ladies and gentlemen was
supposed to be a war to end all wars and
for two whole decades that hope held out
in this country it held out and got
stronger when the economy crumbled after
1929 it held out after the Japanese
attacks upon Manchuria and China the
Italian attacks upon Abyssinia another
of Hitler's attacks upon Austria
Czechoslovakia Poland the Netherlands
even the fall of France even the Battle
of Britain but it was no good in
December 1941 the Japanese attacked
Pearl Harbor four days later Adolf
Hitler declared war on this country
America would fight in a far greater
wider conflict now across the Atlantic
North Africa Italy France also but also
the entire Pacific realm it would fight
as part of a much broader alliance now
when the war was over it committed
itself to leading a new world order it
would lead the newly established United
Nations he would create the World Bank
the IMF and so many other structures of
international cooperation it would
establish the NATO alliance in all that
diplomacy and creativity many jelly's
would again be centrally involved the
United States would spread its naval
bases around the world it would put its
air bases all over Europe Asia the
Middle East
it would have American soldiers
including obviously
soldiers from New England and
Connecticut on the ground in so many
foreign places low
man killed in action will be brought
home from Korea from Vietnam from Iraq
and Afghanistan they are still being
brought home today it is difficult for
this historian to imagine a circumstance
where not will not be so almost two and
a half centuries after the American
Revolution this Republic is all over the
world we have troops in 50 countries
perhaps more we would all like to return
to that more peaceful condition of the
years before 1917 or the 1920s but many
of us cannot see how pulling away from
the rest of the world right now can be
done politically practically militarily
morally we are ironically the very
victim of our own size our greatness our
relative power across the globe former
Secretary of State Madeleine Albright is
fond of calling us the indispensable
nation we pay a large price for that
accolade we do not know what the future
will bring ladies and gentlemen for this
world or this Republic for the Armed
Services of America and our servicemen
and women wherever they are
there is much evil abroad in this world
and the cause to contest that evil are
many this is a time when heavy heavy
responsibilities lie upon our leaders
and when we pray for them to show
intelligence care
and integrity intelligence care and
integrity we yearn almost nostalgically
for the leadership of country witnessed
at the time say of franklin roosevelt
marshall Stimson and Acheson whatever
the future began whatever the future
brings to their our nation it is to
memorialize the past we've come together
today in 1917 and 1918 America stepped
forward into a new role and so indeed
did Yale but the price and lives was a
heavy one and is therefore very proper
that we have stopped at this time to
mark their sacrifice as we walk away
from our ceremony this afternoon
therefore we should do so both in
gratitude and humility may we also walk
away finally in the hope that one day we
may cease to ravage this earth thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Veterans Day my name is Jack
Beecher I'm the veteran military liaison
at Yale University a hundred years ago
this was a day of celebration and today
as we celebrate our veterans I have the
distinct honor to present a special
acknowledgement from veterans to a
veteran Tommo platon Yale class of 1967
US Navy 1967 to 1971 an immediate past
president of the Yale Veterans
Association has been an indefatigable
force in developing the strategies
coalition's and support required for
rapprochement between the University and
the military which has resulted in the
return of the naval and Air Force ROTC
detachments to New Haven and to the
presence of 116 ROTC Midshipmen and
cadets at Yale from the vantage point of
2018 it looks as though the return of
ROTC was inevitable it was not that it
looks the way it now shows how inclusive
the support has grown to be on campus
but it might not have happened and
probably would not if not for Tom's
savvy resolute leadership his work was
patient determined and relentless as he
surrounded himself with allies fellow
Yale alumni veterans students with an
actor with an interest in the future
military service faculty with expertise
in history and global affairs and many
others who felt that Yale with its
tradition of public service had lost an
important opportunity to support the
development of new leaders in the
military the government and all fields
of civic life when Yale discontinued its
long
relationship with the ROTC when I asked
someone who had worked very closely with
Tom about how he had managed this feat
the reply was quote Tom's was simply a
tiger in achieving this goal it is a
privilege to present this award on
behalf of the military and veteran
organizations at Yale the ROTC units the
Yale Veterans Association the Student
Veterans Association and the Yale
veterans Network I know Tom does not
consider his work done he is a man who
was in the service and who continues the
Yale and military traditions to be of
service
Tom please accept this small token of
our appreciation for your guidance
leadership and friendship thank you
[Applause]
thank you jack for those uh wonderful
and kind words this has truly been an
awesome journey for me it started in the
summer of 2010 when I was rummaging
around the Harvard alumni website and I
found something called the Harvard
veterans alumni organization what's that
so I had to join it of course but I
caught up the aya immediately and said
do we have a group like that at Hill and
the director then said no we don't but
we'll create a better one and I'm not
sure that I believed them at that point
but the incredible support that I've
gotten here and we've all gotten here at
Yale has been truly astounding more
support than those fellows up at
Cambridge of God and I would add it's a
why a has just fully behind the effort
that we've been here that we've made and
all those groups
yo veterans Network Yale student
veterans councils Yale students for
veterans
aya veterans liaison office ROTC units
are wonderful undergraduate Eli Whitney
program veterans have all come together
as a community to make veterans and the
military feel comfortable on campus our
motto was true to her traditions because
as Professor Kennedy just mentioned this
has been a Yale tradition since she was
created so this has just been wonderful
but not only the military affiliated
people there are a number of other
people on the campus who have so
supported what we've done things like
heroes day at the bowl which was which
we partnered with the athletic
department and all the veteran and
military groups and had the veterans the
blind veterans from the West Haven a VA
hospital come over to be escorted by our
Midshipmen and cadets that's a wonderful
day for them because they really love to
see you young people and see what you're
up to and be escorted around and enjoy
the day the welcome to campus barbeque
another partnership partnership with all
these groups but the police department
girls at that event has volunteered to
do that several years ago and the
graduate school hosted us at the
courtyard this is again so much support
that we have gotten we couldn't have
done any of these things without all the
people in this room the first veterans
conference at an Ivy League institution
was spearheaded by the aya it was done
replicated at then at West Point and
last year at Princeton so incredible
events and incredible efforts and
activities have taken place when I look
back on this and we were all very unsure
as to how the ROTC units would be
accepted and the acceptance has been
wonderful
I make the other wonderful thing this
happened is true is to recognize Yale's
iconic military figures Hiram Bingham
and his award for the Air Force and
Admiral David s Ingalls his bus sits in
the Navy offices and the Ingalls
foundation gave us at a grant to have
the Admiral David S Ingalls Leadership
Award at the president's review I mean
so many people from foundations and
alumni and existing faculty and students
have supported this effort that it is
truly it posed me away quite frankly so
I want to thank you for your support and
I want to leave you with one thought
about the future stay engaged stay
vigilant so that what we've accomplished
today never goes away and some future
crisis that the country may have thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let us pray as we gather here to honor
those who have served and to break our
time together meaningful Oh Lord we ask
you to bless those who have given so
much and struggled so hard for the glory
of this nation we pray O Lord that
society will be improved and bettered by
what has been done that we learned
together how to live with one another
and we bless now those who have served
us so well and ask you to offer your
blessing upon them grant that we may
live in peace and love and justice
throughout all of our lives oh man
as we continue to retire our colors I'd
like to think on behalf of the
University all of you for joining us
today as we honor our veterans and mark
the centennial of the World War one
armistice can we give another round of
applause throughout all of our veterans
in
[Applause]
I hope that you will visit secretary led
you or read the Yale news articles to
learn more about all the additional
activities that will take place this
week to mark this very special
anniversary my thanks to the Veterans
Day committee - Adrienne Bonham burger
the president of the Yale Veterans
Association and to the Yale students for
veterans for organizing all of the
events this week I especially want to
thank the members of our community who
made today's ceremony so special
president salad it Salameh Professor
Paul Kennedy for his wonderful remarks
in history vice president Janet Lindner
veterans and military liaison Jack
Beecher the Yale police police
department color guard and the Yale
brass ensemble under the direction of
Tom Duffy as well as our ROTC units many
thanks to the staff the many staff who
contributed their time to this ceremony
especially Heather Calabrese and Ryan
Creech oh thank you very much
congratulations to Hillary browning who
gave us an excellent example of keeping
sticking to it I think sticking to it
and who so generously shared her story
and of course the Tommo platon who
provided outstanding volunteers
leadership to bring back ROTC to Yale
and to establish the Yale Veterans
Association and finally before we leave
I ask that when give thank respect and
thanks to the many veterans who are here
with us today once again and to those
who have left us but who are not
forgotten we are eternally grateful and
humble for their service to our nation
and we remember them their intelligence
their care and their integrity best
wishes for today thank you
[Applause]
[Music]